I got real bad I was at my friend's
house we call I called 9-1-1 and then uh
I hung up and I was scared and maybe he
lived in like a good neighborhood or
something but then the firefighters
showed up and like and like someone died
now we went to make sure everything's
okay and the parents like who called
9-1-1 yeah and then like anybody calls I
know I didn't call
[Music]
yeah
a Michigan boy who is six years old
spends one thousand dollars on GrubHub
and reportedly the doorbell just kept on
ringing and cars just kept on coming
six years old he is he's from Michigan
he just kept ordering what did he order
like 50 idiots 50 pizzas or something he
was like racking it up how unsupervised
is this kid so he got he got his dad's
GrubHub account and he just starts going
[__] he must have been hungry huh
yeah he's like having The Rock's cheat
meal and [__]
so The Rock's team heels are crazy
though so they left they left I want a
hot dog cookie there's a dad who's home
alone with his son right his name is the
kid's name is Mason and his wife is away
at the movies with some friends pretty
sure that Dad did for sure dad's got his
headphones on he's [__] playing
Ragnarok and [__]
it's a good game I can understand why
the kid was [__] alone for hours with
surround sound and then this kid's
ordering five large orders of jumbo
shrimp salads Shawarma and chicken Pita
sandwiches chili cheese fries ice cream
grape leaves rice and that was just
that's [__] like Middle Eastern crazy
I I wasn't expecting all those kinds of
fun and that was just the first it was
like wiener schnitzel [__] Lebanese
restaurant
surprise you got some salad yeah as a
six-year-old with some jumbo shrimp yeah
so this was ordering a feast isn't it
Boiling Crab
he says he let his kid use his cell
phone to play a mobile game for about
half an hour before bed and then he
never thought that he'd be like in
GrubHub just like [__] adding to cart
he's like oh that looks good that looks
good this dad was never a kid no for
sure I love this GrubHub game
tacos burritos I mean grape leaves how
does he even know what that is that's
like a side order too
so um the dad says that he's six years
old so you kind of can't even be mad at
him because it doesn't really register
yeah what the [__] is taika 6 yet no no
five but do you think he'd understand
that he'd be ordering GrubHub if he was
picked like if those things showed up at
the house
oh he would like if I gave him a food
app yeah he'd probably know how to go oh
for sure donuts for sure ice cream
cookies but do you think he would know
that clicking that brings it to the door
yeah yeah he knows for sure because like
Wiki sees mom and dad do it so like
we'll be like talking about something
like oh can we have like red velvet
pancakes I'm like whatever what are you
talking about like just order it
just order it
so
[Laughter]
um they they had to they were trying to
explain to him like we took money out of
his piggy bank to pay for this bag of
food and that's how they kind of like
registered it to him how much does he
have in his piggy bank exactly not a
grand unless he's rolling dude his kids
are dead already yeah he's loaded this
kid
um there's so much food that have been
ordered from so many different places
the Chase Bank actually sent them a
fraud alert declining a 439 order a
dollar order from Happy's Pizza
however the 183 order of jumbo shrimp
from the same restaurant did go through
so he's ordering different shift
different orders at the same restaurant
oh [__] at the same time that's why
Chase is good dude oh he's like dude I
got to get past this fraud
God man damn it took a few orders did
they're like Thor just had a [__]
massive pyramid of bags so it took a
couple orders and the dad starts to
realize what the [__] going on he said
he said and then he said after he
realized what's going on there was just
nothing he could do to stop all the food
from coming like it just kept on yeah
right doorbell doorbell doorbell car car
car doorbell doorbell God he just
doesn't know when it's gonna end so he
just has to pack all this food away yeah
he's thinking it could go for days
I got this [__] jumbo shrimp in the
house man he's like you know taking old
peas out of the freezer and [__] like
trying to figure out how to make room I
think you can't subscribe to food
exactly yeah dude you know signing up
for freshly yeah well at least hopefully
a lot of it is stuff like pizza you know
what I mean yeah but then he had a full
[__] six tier wedding cake show up
and then a wedding cake yeah dude
walking up marching a wedding cake
through the front door four piano movers
and then a girl pops out in the order of
the strippers yeah there's a stripper
inside she was funny giant wheels of
cheese they said right that read the
story if this was around when we were
kids we would have probably done this
dumb [__] too man oh yeah dude this is
just the new version of like oh my kid
bought ten thousand dollars worth of
fortnite well you know how you could you
could order back in the day you just
would call a pizza place yeah and
they'll just come yeah yeah and you have
those coupons yeah you know you get two
large pizzas and free breakfast that
you'd be there they would just trust
that you have the cash I remember yeah
my parents would give me like 10 bucks
or whatever and then they're just like
we're gonna go out so order your own
dinner and then I would call you you
could either have Chinese or Pizza Hut
it's just crazy that there's no way they
can guarantee that it's a real call
that's how we built our independence
Maybe by being home alone yeah I would
like a media pizza with pepperoni and
then like it's like a child like [__]
Colin dude I remember calling 9-1-1
because I saw a commercial for a Batman
toy and I was like oh [__] I need that
Batman but pretty bad and so I called
9-1-1 I was like hello I would like to
talk to my dad because if you just hang
out there for a while they say please
hang up and down the operator I was like
the operators I think that's 9-1-1 and
then I asked for my dad all right like
if you leave the phone on the tile the
dial tone and then and then my dad
picked up I [__] up real bad I was at
my friend's house we call I called 9-1-1
and then uh I hung up and I was scared
and maybe he lived in like a good
neighborhood or something but then the
firefighter showed up and like and like
someone died now I want you to make sure
everything's okay and the parents like
who called 9-1-1 yeah and then they're
like did anybody calls I know I didn't
call
that's protocol though if there if
someone calls 9-1-1 and then they pick
up and you hang up yeah they always send
someone yeah they usually call back
right away and then oh and then they all
send someone right after you think they
still do that to this day no I don't
know I don't know because it's on your
cell phone right if you pick up and hang
or you call and hang up they'll come if
you report a crime they won't come
that's very true especially in East L.A
um so as Bart was showing us this
morning yes uh so
this guy
um he's he's telling he's like still
lecturing his kid about this [__] and
like in the middle of lecturing his kid
he's just like Hey Dad did the pepperoni
pizzas come yet
in the middle of it in the middle of
explaining what the [__]
ing could never tell him he's just
freestyle and he no he had to walk out
of the room he didn't no dude I'm sure
it's written on there dude check Ryan it
says that right I don't want to know
it's right there February pizza's come
yet
[Laughter]
um so he just said there's nothing I
could do eventually I just sort of like
laid down and went into a like huddled
up into a ball because I could all I
could do is see the orders keep being
delivered in my bank account being
drained
so he's just like how much is a grand
worth of ordered like food I wonder how
many like depends on what restaurant
yeah I mean a grand like from Happy
Pizza
yeah dude have you seen that there were
dudes that figured out during covid but
there was a glitch that wasn't taking
money out of your bank account when
you're ordering food no yeah they
figured it out on postmate and so they
just kept ordering and then like a year
and a half later it caught up and they
got the bill oh my God 100 000 or
whatever tens of thousands of dollars
dude you can't forget that's [__]
sick yeah it was a cool ass like like I
guess there's some processing thing
happened and then it flagged later
he says it looked like it was about to
be over by around 2 A.M that's when most
of the restaurants in this area were
closed however why that people are
staying late for this guy by that time
there was an order that came from Buca
di Beppo that he could only describe as
a sink
zinc amount of spaghetti and marinara
sauce and you got to throw that out I
mean that's just a sink amount you gotta
invite the whole neighborhood over at
that point dude if you get spaghetti
meatballs at Buca you gotta throw that
out he called it an industrial kitchen
sink
amount of spaghetti and marinara I don't
like ordering food like most it just
doesn't taste good it doesn't taste we
eat ordered food here all the time
because we have to yeah at the same time
I get it but I'm just saying I don't
order I'm with him though I order you
order steak and eggs I do order at a
convenience though out of convenience
but eating at the restaurant is way
better times better well obviously
yeah but a lot of people prefer ordering
because they don't like going out so
that's like yeah
if I can I always go out too and I don't
want to clean up even if it's ordering
you have to clean up and throw it away
you know something they have the time to
go out and they'll order it guys this is
an insane tape do you want me to edit
this out you know what's crazy nobody's
gonna
agree with it sometimes food is better
hot
less than a handful of things that are
okay when you deliver like what pizza
Barely There Here We Go Again JK group
mine yeah okay barely only Pizza Hut in
the heat wave that's what I'm saying
okay that's good I agree with that it's
It's gotta be it's gotta be that but
most Pizza you could reheat and it's
still solid like hey you know what
though you can't get the fries no unless
you got an air fryer air fryer air fryer
change the game dude but then you might
start cooking exactly if you're gonna
heat up the oven not the same though
it's not the same it's not the same what
about sushi hell no you crazy
throw that in the air fryer if you get
that too goes fine okay any stews I
think it's fine
you gotta you gotta heat it you gotta
heat up the pan is it isn't Sushi to go
against your culture though
it actually is the beginning of the
culture
and how we got to feudal
[Music]
foreign